holy frijoles antonio banderas joke
crazy
skin I live in stars antoniou Banderas
and it's directed by Pedro almodóvar I'm
sure I said that absolutely wrong it's
about a plastic surgeon played by Ben
Darras who becomes obsessed with
creating the perfect skin that could be
completely impervious to injury burn cut
anything after his wife dies in a bad
car crash he becomes incredibly
disturbed with this idea of creating
this perfect skin
Norma
Norma this is a foreign ailments and
English subtitles of Spanish language
and for me really that's sometimes a
hard thing because I like to watch
movies I don't like to read movies but
this film is so good this is like a
Spanish Alfred Hitchcock film it's so
finely crafted and so finely tuned there
is not one scene in this film that is
out of place it's told in a nonlinear
fashion and that's all I'm going to say
I will not spoil anything about this
film
if you don't mind watching a foreign
film and if you like Antonio Banderas
like I do you'll probably love this film
this is one of those movies where if you
look away or kind of not pay attention
for a scene you will miss huge plot
points because this isn't one of those
movies where the plot is spoken to you
and where you learn things because
someone says it and you're able to
figure things out by looks characters
give each other thought processes the
way the film is made it's it's
storytelling with directing and that is
how you direct a movie the best way to
direct a movie is when you can tell a
story with the camera you don't have to
have someone come out and explain it all
to you and this film is very suspenseful
extremely dramatic and disturbing in a
lot of ways it is very much so like an
Alfred Hitchcock film except Spanish
it paints a portrait of a man who's
slowly going extremely insane but you
wouldn't be able to tell looking in from
the outside and Tony Banderas is so good
here this is a really good year for him
he had the puss and boots is I really
liked and now this his performance here
is so excellent it might be the best I
have ever seen him the main actors of
the film also I don't remember her name
but she is one of the most beautiful
Spanish women I've ever seen in my life
the way this film was directed the way
the film was written the way it's acted
is so reminiscent of old-school cinema
that I wish Americans make more movies
like this it doesn't it
there have been a lot of art films this
year that disappointed me and there have
been some that got a lot of praise and I
just didn't really get it but this film
is extremely intense and it just it
really it really got under my skin ah
that's interesting since he is a plastic
surgeon there are some scenes where you
see him doing some of his work so if
you're a little squeamish in regards to
that this probably isn't the best movie
for you I honestly have no issues with
this film I adored this movie I think
it's one of the best films of the year
I'm going to give it an A I loved it and
Tony about Daris was great in it all the
acting was excellent
the writing was good and it really pulls
the blanket out from under you it has a
lot of things not going to expect it's a
really good film or the best of the year
if you liked this review you can
subscribe my channel and get stuck when
I